why men cheat we're talking about on
average you know because people can
cheat for a variety of different reasons
but on average men
cheat because they have this desire for
sexual variety and so you see this in
some clear cases like I to pick an older
example a Hugh Grant
Elizabeth Hurley drop dead gorgeous
um model actress whatever and then he's
caught you know having sex with a
prostitute on the street now you're like
what's going on he's not he's basically
trying to satisfy his desire for sex
right and people look at that and think
he's crazy because you know he's he's
with this gorgeous woman it's not
because she's better looking or higher
inmate value it's just that she's
different